[Musique]
bonsoir très heureux de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez pour cette nouvelle édition
voici les titres de ce lundi 9 novembre
dans moins d'un mois c'est le 34e
téléthon le week-end caritatif pour la
recherche contre les maladies génétiques
un événement qui se tiendra cette année
mais remodelé en raison de la crise
sanitaire comment les organisateurs
prépare-t-il cette édition reportage à
magny les hameaux et à villepreux et
puis invité daniel basant coordinateur
du téléthon dans le secteur est des
yvelines la ville de bois d'arcy a un
nouveau maire l'ex premier adjoint jean
philippe plus a été élu samedi au cours
du conseil municipal
il succède à philippe benassaya devenu
député de la 11e circonscription des
yvelines qui a démissionné de son mandat
communal et puis les directions plaisir
dans ce journal avec leur confinement la
municipalité a renforcé son service
maintien à domicile pour les personnes
fragiles une dizaine d'agents de la
mairie qui est mobilisé mais avant de
développer ses titres l'épidémie de kovy
de 19 avec ces derniers chiffres pour le
département des yvelines elle vous le
voyez sur une semaine on observe une
baisse pour le taux de tests positifs et
de taux et d'incidences c'est à dire le
nombre de cas positifs pour 100000
habitants sans doute les premiers effets
du couvre-feu et du confinement elle
mais de l'autre côté la situation
s'aggrave dans les hôpitaux 93,2 % des
lits de réanimation sont désormais
occupés en ile-de-france et dans les
yvelines 154 hospitalisations
supplémentaires ont été enregistrées en
une semaine
70 personnes étaient hier toujours en
réanimation et depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire 703 personnes sont
mortes du coronavirus dans les hôpitaux
du département
[Musique]
les 4 et 5 décembre prochain ce sera le
34e téléthon 30 heures de mobilisation
pour la recherche médicale sur les
maladies génétiques on en parle avec
daniel basons bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
le coordinateur du téléthon pour le
secteur est des yvelines c'est un
téléthon qui aura bel et bien lieu ça a
été confirmé mais la période sanitaire
forcément rabat les cartes et oblige les
organisateurs à modifier quelque peu
l'événement exemple dans ce reportage à
magny les hameaux et à vil prix
le zonage chantal mauduit restera fermé
les 4 et 5 décembre prochains à magny
les hameaux les bénévoles ne pourront
pas être dans la tradition apporter du
spectacle et du plaisir en famille et
entre amis
pour cette nouvelle édition du téléthon
ce serait essentiellement de la collecte
on a commencé à faire une activité il ya
quelques semaines en a vendu des huîtres
lors d'une brocante locale ça a permis
de faire un petit chiffon pas pas
extraordinaire mais un petit gîte quand
même et le week-end du 4-5 nous serons
sur le pont avec notamment six points
dans la ville où nous ferons des
collectes avec un petit peu d'animation
tout en respectant les gestes bas
des animations qui n'existeront pas non
plus du côté de villepreux l'association
aurait dû célébrer ses 25 ans cette
année les bénévoles vise plutôt un
programme numérique
on a pensé à organiser par le biais de
facebook
instagram donc une tombola quand même on
essaye aussi je sais pas si ça va être
envisageable mais on essaye de maintenir
le flash mob qui sera fait à domicile
avec l'envoi de vidéos sur cette musique
de jérusalem
même sans week end animé les bénévoles
veulent respecter le thème de l'année
trop fort avec des records à battre en
2019 magny les hameaux a récolté plus de
27000 euros
villepreux plus de 30000 euros ou pas du
tout d'animation cette année daniel base
ont tant elle est commune yvelinoise on
le sait les communes il une hausse qui
sont très engagés à chaque année dans le
secteur est divine en faveur du téléthon
et ce chiffre aussi au niveau national
les animations partout en france ça
représente 40 % des dons environ du
téléthon soit environ 30 millions
d'euros
est ce que c'est de nature à vous
inquiéter cette année que ce téléthon ne
puisse pas se tenir dans des conditions
normales bien sûr en est on est assez
inquiet vis-à-vis nous organisateurs
parce qu'ils ont déjà beaucoup fait pour
maintenir ce manifeste est en route
ben may
comme vous l'avez dit le téléthon
soutiendra un bien
les 4 et 5 décembre ça puisse se tenir
dans des bois nation particulière se
tiendra dans des particules dans les
manifestations diverses enfin un petit
peu un clos fermé on va dire parce qu'il
ya les mesures sanitaires qui sent là
mais on espère quand même que les dons
seront l'un pour la recherche que le
sien pour nono manade
c'est ce que vous disiez en préparant
cette interview c'est les dons cette
année qui seront très importants et il
ya notamment un travail de votre pas en
tant qu'ordinateur essayer de trouver de
nouvelles villes pour en anticiper voilà
on essaie quand même de bonnes sollicité
toutes les villes qui faisait pas le thé
des temps jusqu'à maintenant donc la
force était en 2019 en était à 331 892
sur la main coordination avec une clope
collecte globale de plus d'un million
quatre cent vingt avec la télématique
toussaint on espère que le report va se
faire donc ce qu'on peut dire faites le
prendre 6 37 mais fée des dents
venez partout mais de vote enveloppes
fait des dents partout où vous pourrez
en sera là avec le numéro et sites
internet qui s'affiche
du coup dans les yeux ça va se dérouler
vous l'avez dit on va se reporter
principalement sur les dons est ce que
quand même de petites animations vont
pouvoir se tenir deux petites opérations
même si le contexte on ne sait pas
comment il va évoluer peut-être que le
confinement doit être aussi prolongé
vous avez aujourd'hui c'est un vrai que
réellement des petites manifs et sept
gérants des tombolas des trucs comme ça
en ligne mais sur le terrain
on incite
on demande à nous organisateurs de
rester très vigilant de ne pas s'exposer
comme voilà c'est ce une année
réellement exceptionnel maintenant on
compte vraiment sur les donateurs qui
fête ses 36 35
et puis qu'ils nous envoient les des
enveloppes dans avec cette année aussi
des nouveautés alors une nouveauté en
ligne ça c'est une nouveauté au niveau
national avec un grand tombola une
grande tombola pardon qui sera organisée
c'est ça quel est le principe du coût de
la tombola est organisée par la fn
donc chacun au maintien quand même les
contraint donc en ayant un contre un en
un site où les organisateurs peuvent
aller se connecter pour faire cette
tombola
puis on a beaucoup de choses qui
apparaissent vous savez nous nous
organisateurs sans beaucoup
d'imagination et on un ce1 c est
sceptique sur sur la façon on pense
quand même que bon il n'y donc cent
moins élevé ça c'est sûr mais sans se
réinventer un peu et telles conditions
je remercie les lions ce parce que les
lions sont non c'est une opération
chaque lion se
un des rangs va recevoir un paquet de
dix enveloppes dans qui va distribuer
auprès de sa famille tous hommes ou des
voisins
donc là aussi on est soit parce que les
cas du temps note
grosse manifestation de versailles du
pâté n'aura pas lieu
donc on espère que le sa main se
rattraper avec les enveloppes des
grosses manifestations pas lieu on l'a
compris saraba totalement les cartes
vous parliez des lions ce club qui est
un réseau très présent dans les yvelines
et qu'il ya un réseau même au niveau
mondial et juste pour préciser que sur
cette tombola dont on parle est la
grande tombola il ya des lots d'une
centaine d'artistes un des chanteurs des
sportifs des comédiens aussi et c'est en
partenariat avec l'association star
solidaire qui a été monté cette grande
tombola il nous reste quelques quelques
secondes encore dans cet entretien pour
lancer un appel peut être aux yvelinois
qu'avez vous envie de leur dire qu'on
appelle évincé de de faire le 36 37
et partout où pourrait il y aura des
points dans donc fait des deux en fait
des dents pour pour la rochère tout ça
on a encore besoin en encore une grande
route encore à tenir
je veux remercier aussi les pompiers qui
pourront pas être présents mais c'est
pareil qui distribue des des enveloppes
dans donc fait le 36 37
l'appel est lancé c'est très important
pour faire continuer cette recherche une
recherche qui progresse dans la lutte
contre les maladies génétiques avec
notamment un des tentes des thérapies
géniques 1 qui sont directement financé
1 par ses laboratoires
grâce à vos dons donc c'est très
important merci daniel besoin d'être
venu en plateau bien c'est moins que
vous a remis ses ordinateurs du téléthon
dans le secteur est des yvelines
merci beaucoup
dans l'actualité de ce lundi c'était il
ya un demi-siècle général de gaulle
disparaissait à presque 80 ans dans sa
résidence de colombey les deux églises
le 9 novembre 1970
cinquante ans après l'héritage du
général demeure auprès de nombreux élus
à politiques qui se réclament encore de
lui à commencer par gérard larcher le
président du sénat sénateur des yvelines
dans un message adressé aux membres de
l'amicale gaulliste du sénat l'ancien
maire défend l'idée du gaullisme c'est
l'amour de la france au 21ème siècle
être gaulliste aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
être nostalgique c'est au contraire agir
pour maintenir vivante une certaine idée
de la france de l'état de la nation et
de la république afin d'éclairer et
d'élever la pensée et l'action future de
jeunes générations fin de citation le
général de gaulle un homme également
célébrée par tous les français et tous
les partis politiques avance valérie
pécresse sur twitter est la nostalgie
elle ne suffit pas pour la présidente de
la région ile de france je cite dans
notre monde périlleux la grandeur
française reste un combat notre combat
est la député de la 5e circonscription
des yvelines à yale brawn peavey se
souvient-elle des mots du général de
gaulle sur l'espérance et des mots qui
doivent rappeler aux français la
grandeur de leur nation et qui peut
triompher contre toutes les épreuves un
parallèle et donc fait avec la crise
actuelle crise sanitaire aussi une crise
sécuritaire du moment enfin une dernière
réaction à vous proposer celle
d'ensemble pour les yvelines au groupe
des élus majoritaires du conseil
départemental qui rend hommage à l'homme
qui n'a jamais cédé pour la france
commémoration également du côté de
certaines villes des yvelines c'est le
cas notamment vous allez le voir sur ces
quelques images à saint-germain-en-laye
cérémonie dans les jardins de l'hôtel de
ville avec dépôt de gerbe devant la
stèle du général
enfin à ces quelques images d'archivés
aussi pour se rappeler que le général de
gaulle est venu à plusieurs reprises sur
le territoire yvelinois pour des sommets
et diplomatiques notamment au château de
versailles de champs sur marne et dans
la résidence aussi présidentielle du
château de rambouillet où il a accueilli
le président américain eisenhower
c'était en 1959
je vous le disais dans les titres bois
d'arcy la ville de bois d'arcy compte un
nouveau maire depuis samedi après la
démission de philippe benassaya jean
philippe lucas a été élu à l'issue du
dernier conseil municipal
astrid berges heures pour les précisions
c'est officiel
on finit plus est devenu maire de bois
d'arcy ce samedi 7 novembre
il succède à philippe benassaya
démissionnaire après avoir été élu
député pour respecter la loi du non
cumul des mandats
le nouveau maire n'est pas inconnu dans
la commune il y a toujours vécu et
occupe depuis quelques années des
fonctions politiques
j'ai l'occasion en cours de ces derniers
mandats afin du cac depuis 2014 à être
sur quatre délégations des différentes
dont les finances qui me permets moi
d'avoir une vision globale mais assez
globale de la situation et la proximité
que j'ai avec avec notre ancien maire et
député aujourd'hui fait que j'ai une
bonne connaissance aussi des sujets
importants pour notre commune un nouveau
maire qui entend poursuivre les projets
engagés par son prédécesseur
aujourd'hui c'est une belle journée
parce que c'est une zone qui consacre
aussi la continuité des projets la
continuité l'équipe ce que j'ai mis en
marche ce que j'ai mis en projet je suis
à la fois heureux pour jean-philippe
heureux pour l'équipe est rassuré parce
que tours a continué comme avant et je
serai bien sûr là pour continuer à
veiller à la bonne application du
programme
l'opposition de son côté estime qu'il ya
eu un manque de concertation
nous trouvons que c'est bien dommage de
ne pas avoir laissé le choix que
monsieur lui s'était imposée dès les
premières minutes du départ de monsieur
benassaya et que dans les guides du
maire comme chacun le sait il est bien
noté que ce n'est pas au maire sortant
de donner le nom de son
successeur trois grands projets à venir
pour jean fils et plus la reconstruction
du centre de loisirs de la colombe la
crèche ambroise paré et le marché
couvert
en bref un adolescent d'elancourt de 15
ans entre la vie et la mort il a été
touché par au moins deux coups de
couteau au niveau du thorax samedi
dernier à l'origine une rixe entre
jeunes qui a mal tourné les faits se
sont produits à samedi vers 17 heures 55
dans le parc des coudrais en face du
quartier des petits prés la victime
connue des services de police pour des
faits de violence a été transféré à
l'hôpital militaire de percy à clamart
deux autres personnes ont été également
blessées pour l'heure les enquêteurs
n'ont identifié aucun suspect les
investigations sont en cours
un homme de 30 ans placé en détention
provisoire et déférés devant la justice
pour port d'armes samedi il a été
retrouvé dans les couloirs de la caserne
de pompiers à les pompiers de paris à
bois d'arcy à bois d'arcy à bailly
pardon c'était à bailly l'individu qui
souffre de troubles psychiatriques était
en possession d'un long couteau lors de
la fouille de son téléphone les
gendarmes qui ont interpellé l'individu
ont découvert également des images du
drapeau de l'état islamique son projet
son procès se tiendra le 3 décembre aux
clayes-sous-bois une situation qui agace
le maire et les habitants la nouvelle
halle du marché de la ville quasiment
terminée n'est toujours pas ouverte la
raison un dysfonctionnement qui concerne
les portes coupe-feu lé précision dans
ce sujet de michael et demi d'euros son
inauguration se fait attendre depuis
plusieurs semaines le nouveau marché des
clayes-sous-bois situé en face de
l'ancienne halle n'est toujours pas
ouvert alors que les travaux ont débuté
au dernier trimestre 2010 8 et semble
presque terminé une situation qui
interpelle les habitués savent hier soir
depuis le temps qu'on attend c'est un
peu agaçant
alors c'est inadmissible et anton 30
arrêts pour deux dans ce dossier les
maîtres d'oeuvre est pointé du doigt par
la municipalité
je vous donne un exemple très très
précis concernant ce dernier auteur dans
le dans le cahier des charges et il
n'avait pas été prévu suffisamment
clairement par le maître d'oeuvre que
sur certaines portes du bâtiment ses
portes soient des portes coupe feu et
qu'il y ait également
sas à l'intérieur de certaines pièces
voilà ceci a été découvert très très
tardivement d'où le décalage d'ouverture
la municipalité espère maintenant
pouvoir ouvrir cette nouvelle halle dans
la première quinzaine de décembre
la structure est très attendu par les
commerçants ça nous permettra bien sûr
donc de valoriser encore mieux les
produits qui sont issus de notre
territoire et tous les bons produits que
l'on trouve sur les marchés
ça va déjà être plus récent plus plus
moderne
là c'est un marché qui est vétuste ça va
changer tous les atouts des étalages ça
va être joli quoi au final le projet a
coûté près de 4,9 millions d'euros une
fois la nouvelle halle ouverte l'ancien
marché sera démoli laissera la place à
un programme immobilier de 35 logements
avec le 2ème confinement et l'épidémie
de kovy 19 difficile pour les personnes
les plus fragiles d'aller faire leurs
courses normalement à plaisir la
municipalité dans ce contexte renforce
de nouveau son service de maintien à
domicile une dizaine d'agents y est
mobilisé mélanie poquet une séance de
course presque ordinaire marie-louise
achète ce jour là un peu de frais mais
pas pour elle elle est agent social de
la ville de plaisir elle suit donc
scrupuleusement la liste de courses
on est attentif à ça il faut bien qu'on
leur apporte vraiment ce dont ils ont
besoin
bon il peut pas sortir avec le
confinement
c'est claude berger qui lui a remis sa
liste ce plaisir a bénéficié depuis deux
ans des aides du service maintien à
domicile un service à nouveau modifié
dix personnes fragiles en ont fait la
demande
avec ce virus qui se propage partout ça
m'empêche d'accompagner la personne de
la mairie mais je me faisais à la fois
une sortie et les cours se voyait alors
c'était agréable d'écouter beaucoup 68
repas sont distribués chaque jour
accompagnement pour des rendez vous
médicaux ou administratifs et appels
téléphoniques
une dizaine de personnes est mobilisée
dans ce service
qu'ils sachent que nous sommes présents
et nous répondons systématiquement de
façon personnalisée aux à leur retour à
nos sms
les personnes qui sont vraiment très
isolés nous allons les faire sortir de
chez eux pour une petite demi heure
voilà une petite balade aux alentours de
leur domicile pour
d'effacer un petit peu ce ciseau
allemand ça service renforcé proposé par
la mairie pendant toute la durée du
confinement
il s'adaptera en fonction des annonces
gouvernementales à venir
cette mobilisation hier dimanche à
versailles de 600 personnes de
confession catholique elles se sont
réunies sur le parvis de la cathédrale
saint louis pour faire entendre leur
voix demander au gouvernement
d'autoriser là tenue des messes les
célébrations sont interdites avec le
confinement les lieux de culte eux
restent ouverts pour la prière
individuelle à l'origine de ce
rassemblement un appel lancé sur les
réseaux sociaux par trois étudiants elle
était suspendue m'a été de nouveau
autorisé temporairement par arrêté du
préfet des yvelines il s'agit de la
chasse de certaines espèces nuisibles
comme les sangliers les chevreuils et
les serres une décision pour réguler la
population de la faune sauvage
susceptible d'occasionner des dégâts aux
cultures aux forêts et aux biens ces
interventions sont définies par des
modalités strictes pas de repas de
convivialité entre les chasseurs et
limitation du nombre de personnes en
voiture ou encore port du masque
obligatoire
enfin avant de refermer ce journal cette
action de la région ile de france depuis
2010 9 elle propose son chèque numérique
une aide pouvant aller jusqu'à 1500
euros pour permettre le développement
numérique des sociétés un enjeu de
taille en pleine crise sanitaire pour
que les petites et moyennes entreprises
puissent se digitalise et interview
express collectées par nicolas landry
[Musique]
chez numérique
il a été créé en fin 2018 pour aider les
commerçants à ceux numérisés et à être
plus compétitifs notamment par rapport à
tout commerce en ligne et les grandes
surfaces peut être de la création d'un
site internet de la publicité digitale
ça peut être des abonnements à des
marketplace de la formation au numérique
comme je le disais puisqu'on l'a étendu
pendant le premier confinement ça peut
être également des frais de livraison
donc voilà c'est assez vaste et on
s'adapte au fur et à mesure des besoins
que nous remonter à la fin les
commerçants et les restaurateurs
notamment
[Musique]
il faut se rendre sur le site de la
région et donc il ya ce chèque numérique
que vous trouverez donc vous pouvez
candidate et après fournir les factures
et toucher un maximum de 1500 euros faut
savoir que ça ne finance pas 100 % des
dépenses ça c'est des financements
publics
on va jusqu'à 50 % des dépenses là on
voit d'ailleurs un intérêt pour ce
dispositif puisque on a dix fois plus de
demandes au quotidien que par rapport à
avant pour les communes qui voudrait
lancer un moment de mouvements un peu
plus vaste pour au sein d'un ville pour
tous leurs commerçants ont créé des
marketplace local nous à la région avec
valérie pécresse on les accompagne par
le volet 2 du chèque numérique qu'on a
lancé récemment qui va jusqu'à 10000
euros sachant qu'une plateforme locale
comme ça de vente au niveau d'une
commune ça coûte entre 20 et 40 milles
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité et belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]